مشاهدينا الى الخبر العاجل الذي ورد قبل
قليل وظهر على شاشاتنا ويفيد
باطلاق نار على مسيره اسرائيليه من
الاراضي السوريه وفقا لما ذكره الجيش
الاسرائيلي الذي
اضاف بانه تم الرد على مصدر اطلاق النيران
ماذا في تفاصيل هذا الخبر مع نجوان سمري
مراسله الجزيره من القدس نجوى
نعم حسن بالفعل قبل قليل قال بيان مقتضب
للناطق العسكري باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي بان
مسيره استطلاع تابعه له
تعرضت لاطلاق نار خفيف من داخل الاراضي
السوريه عند الحدود بين الجزء المحتل من
الجولان السوري وبين
الجولان في الاراضي السوريه
وقام الجيش جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بالرد
بالمثل من خلال اطلاق نيران
باسلحه رشاشه نحو المنطقه التي تم فيها رز
لاطلاق النار باتجاه هذه
المسيره لكن في البيان يذكر ايضا الناطق
العسكري بان
المسيره لم تتعرض لاي ضرر وانها اكملت
مهمه الاستطلاع لجمع معلومات في الموقع
اي اضرار ووصلت هذه المهمه نذكر ان مثل
هذا
الحادث تكرر عده مرات في محاولات مختلفه
لاطلاق نار واسقاط مسيرات تحلق في معظم
الاوقات على طول الحدود بين جزئي الجولان
الجزء المحتل من قبل اسرائيل او الجزء
السوري وايضا على طول الحدود مع لبنان
طيله الوقت يطير الجيش الاسرائيلي مثل هذه
المسيرات التي تكون بالعاده مسيرات
استطلاع وتجمع معلومات استخباراتيه وكانت
هناك عده محاولات لاسقاط مثل هذه المسيرات
تحديدا من الجانب اللبناني غالبيه
المرات كان الناطق العسكريه الاسرائيلي
يقول بان هذه المسيرات تسقط تسقط جراء خل
تقني او ما شابه
وبانه لا يمكن ربما ان تلحق اي اذى بعد
سقوطها حتى وان سقطت في الجانب السوري او
في الجانب اللبناني ولا يمكن جمع معلومات
هذه بالعاده هي روايه الناطق العسكري
الاسرائيلي لكن حتى الان من غير الواضح
بعد فيما اذا اطلاق النار من الجانب
الاسرائيلي او من جانب قوات جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي قد تسببت باي اضرار في الجانب
السوري ولكن مره اخرى هذا الحادث يتكرر
عده مرات مع مواصله جيش الجيش الاسرائيلي
بتطيير مثل هذه المسيرات التي تحلق على
طول الحدود على طول خط وقف اطلاق النار
بين جانبي
الجولان المحتل والجولان السوري وايضا على
طول الحدود مع لبنان
شكرا جزيلا لكن نجوان سمري حدثنا من القدس